Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
By the way, guys, I was actually ready by the time the first intro part was playing.
But then I was like, no, make them wait.
I was like...
Do I start now after the first time is done?
Or do I just sit there and have two more minutes of me time?
I'm joking, I'm joking.
I love straight for you.
I was just like, no, let me make them wait two more minutes.
Legitimately, I was actually ready.
I just felt like, I was just like, you know what, today I feel, you know, today I feel a little quirky today.
I'm gonna make them wait.
Free lube, we take those.
But good morning, everybody.
Why am I saying good morning?
Well, I woke up at 4 p.m.
today.
Yes, my sleep schedule is a very fucked up right now.
Why is it fucked up?
Well, the first step is admitting that you have a problem.
And you sort of see where it's going towards to.
Um, so, I...
Not again!
Donkey, no!
You said you would...
Look, okay, I may or may not have relapsed last night.
And I may or may not have played 15 hours of Rivals last, last, last night.
And okay, look.
I have a perfect justification for this, guys.
Okay, so like, you know how...
Okay, so, I'm not in the lead of words anymore, of course, cause it's at like 400 points right now.
And, um...
And anyway...
I'm up two games by the way.
Alright, let me rip the band-aid off.
I am only up two games after the 15 hour session.
But, but it's not my fault.
It's not my fault.
So, I...
Okay, so like...
Okay, I'm just a little bit salty here.
But, basically, look.
There is justification...
Look, I'm not like making...
Look, it's not excuses.
There is justification.
I know I sound like an addict trying to find an excuse right now.
But like, this is an addict that has a good justification, guys.
I know it's like the 1%, 99% of addicts...
Usually, usually, it's sort of their fault.
But like, I swear to God, this is not my fault.
This time, I'm one of...
I am the 1% of the addicts.
Anyway...
So...
I...
Okay, so like, you guys must be like, oh, Monday.
She's not streaming on Monday because, you know, she's resting.
And stuff like that.
No, because...
I actually arranged ahead of time...
Asking if I could get a...
If I could play with a 4-stack.
If I could play on a 4-stack.
For rivals.
So I can get it done.
Quote on quote.
Quick.
So I don't have to think about getting on the leaderboards later.
Because I want to be on the leaderboards for the Disguised Toast Tournament.
Because like, they put me in the pro slot.
So I was like, oh man.
I would like to...
I don't know.
I just felt like it's sort of like an ego thing.
Where I was like, well, since I'm on the pro slot.
I feel like I...
I feel like, you know.
I should like, look like I belong there.
Instead of like, being like, why the fuck is she there?
And then...
So like...
But then, look.
I asked every day.
If they were ready.
And if they have the time.
I made my schedule.
To like, for that specific...
I was like, okay.
Monday, right?
I won't stream on Monday.
So I can have the day to play rank.
So like, because they're like, Monday will be free.
And I was like, okay.
Monday, right?
And they're like, yeah, yeah.
Well...
Two of the three people.
On Monday.
Were like, sorry, we couldn't.
We can't make it.
And I was like, are you fucking kidding me?
I was just like, are you...
I hate Mondays.
I...
I fucking hate Mondays.
Anyway.
Two of the three people.
Told me.
On Monday.
That they were not free.
And I was like, I...
I could...
I don't...
I was like, are you fucking kidding me?
I could have been streaming on Monday.
So like...
So then like...
Unfortunately.
Or fortunately.
One person was free.
So we ended up duoing.
And then picking up random...
Not strangers.
But like random people.
I mean, they were sort of like strangers to me.
But like...
We're like, you're good.
And we just ended up like adopting players.
For four stacks.
But it didn't go so well.
It didn't...
It did not go so well.
So like...
After 15 hours.
I am up two games.
And I'm definitely not...
I mean, I'm like 60 points away from the leaderboard.
But...
You know.
I didn't min-max my stack.
I literally...
We got like...
Like...
At one point we bumped into like a really good Widowmaker.
I know.
It's like...
I was just like, fuck it.
They're known as like one of the best Widowmakers in NA.
But like...
Playing around a Widow is not like...
Very ideal.
For the team in general.
Because we have to make sure...
Everybody is willing to play around a Widowmaker.
But like...
Wow.
It's crazy.
Apparently random players want to play characters that they want to play.
Is that fucking insane?
That they all have their own fucking free will.
And...
Their own free will and minds.
To think about themselves.
Instead of like a collectivist.
Thinking about the fucking team.
But no!
We can't play around one single guy.
How did...
I can't believe people are so selfish.
I...
Sorry, Black Widow.
Sorry, I...
My brain is not doing so well.
I meant Black Widow.
I...
It's like...
Okay, it's not my fault.
Why the fuck are they both Widow?
Anyway, sorry.
I meant Black Widow.
We picked up one of the best Black Widows in NA.
And then like...
It's crazy.
Apparently people don't want to play around one person.
Is that insane to think about?
Like...
So...
And then...
So like...
And so...
Yeah, so I had that incident.
So, 15 hours of pure pain and grief.
And that is why I woke up at 4pm.
By the way, I'm a very petty person.
I straight up was like...
Was like...
Never again.
Like...
Cause like...
Okay.
I told them.
I told them, I was like...
That's not...
Like I was like...
Hey...
That is like...
Not...
Not okay.
Because like...
I literally freed up my entire day.
And made my entire schedule.
Just for that day.
Like I moved things around.
And I'm a very busy person.
What was the justification?
Well...
I won't say.
It's like...
It's not like...
Oh, someone died.
It was more so like...
What was like...
I'm EP.
And the other one was like...
I need to spend time with my girlfriend.
And I was like...
In my head, I was...
In my head, I was like...
You can see her everyday.
I was just like...
I'm seeing you once yesterday.
I was like...
Rank over GF.
Too far got into...
Doki, you can't say...
Me or the girlfriend.
Choose.
You can sleep every...
Okay, look.
I'm joking.
I'm joking, guys.
Look.
All I'm saying is...
Rank is life.
Yeah, you could see your girlfriend.
But wouldn't it be so cool to see me?
It would be so cool.
Anyway.
Anyway, so...
So, I was just like...
I was very petty.
Not petty, but also...
I don't like to be pushed over.
So, I was just straight up like...
Hey, that's not okay, guys.
My scheduling is very different.
I actually do have to plan.
Like I said, I plan my schedules...
A week in advance and everything.
So, obviously...
I set stuff up.
I move things around.
Because I was like...
Today is gonna be a rank day.
You know, like happily saying that.
And then, you know...
At the end, I was like...
Today was a rank day.
So...
So, I was like...
Yeah, I was just like...
Today was a rank day.
It could have been a happy rank day...
If I had my min-max stat.
It could have been.
That's the thing.
It could have been a happy rank day.
Instead, it was 15 hours of pure pain and grief.
So, yes.
That is why...
Long story short.
That was why I woke up at 4 PM today.
I actually had my meal.
My first meal of the day.
Still up 2, though.
You know how late...
I played so late.
That my lobbies...
In NA, by the way.
I was in NA lobbies, by the way.
My queues...
I played so fucking late.
It was like the sun's out.
The people in my lobbies were Korean and Chinese people.
Korean and Chinese pro players in my lobby.
The person I was playing with, they were like...
Oh, yeah.
Entire lobby.
Our team is all Korean players.
I was like, what?
People were actually comming in Korean.
I was like, oh my god.
I need help.
I was like...
I was just like...
Oh my god.
This is how down bad I am for ELO.
I am...
I've already like...
I'm in another country now.
I played for so long.
They literally transported me into a different country in NA.
I'm hungry.
I'm hungry for ELO.
Oh my god.
It was crazy.
I was not expecting it.
But I made a new Korean friend.
I made a new Korean friend.
His name is like FunFun.
He's in a team with Happy.
HappyHappy.
I don't like...
Is that crazy?
You might recognize them.
FunFun is part of a team with HappyHappy.
They're both part of one of the best Korean teams in Marvel Rivals.
I love their...
I know I love their name.
And I became friends...
Okay, here's a funny story about...
I know some of you guys are like, Stop talking about Rivals.
I'm sorry.
This is like...
Don't worry.
I have other stuff to talk about.
It's their joy.
I wish their entire team was just like...
FunFun.
HappyHappy.
JoyJoy.
SadSad.
Like if their team names...
If their entire player roster was just those types of names.
That would be so funny.
I think that would be honestly peak.
Anyway...
The thing is...
We kept bumping into FunFun in rank.
And then we lost our...
We lost our trio and four stack of people that we were picking up randomly.
So it was just Duos again.
And obviously, Duos is not that fun because...
It's so RNG.
And so...
We bumped into with FunFun and against FunFun.
But when we got into FunFun, he wasn't on streamer mode.
And apparently, he was on...
He had a phase where all he did was play The Thing.
And then so like...
Every time we had him on our team...
Someone on the enemy team was banning The Thing.
Because he was like playing with him and he's really good at it.
So like...
He kept being like...
Who is it?
Like in the chat.
In like...
In like broken English.
He was like...
Who did The Thing?
Who banned?
And then we were like...
Oh, FunFun.
Why aren't you in streamer mode?
And this happened for like two games straight.
We had him like three games straight.
Back to back to back.
And...
And then so like...
We were like...
FunFun.
And then FunFun was like...
Can I join you guys?
And then we were like...
Put on streamer mode.
And he's like...
No, me noob.
He was like...
Me no play.
And I was just like...
I was like...
Put on streamer mode.
And you can join us.
And he was like...
No, me noob.
Me one carry.
And I was like...
I was like...
Bro.
And then like...
And then we got him on the enemy team.
And then I was like...
We banned The Thing.
Got him on the enemy team.
And I was like...
We banned The Thing.
And then I banned...
I banned The Thing.
And then he was like...
Who?
Who is it?
And then I was like...
FunFun.
Put on streamer mode.
And he was like...
No.
I
was like...
Okay, so...
Okay, I feel like everyone know.
It was like...
I was playing with...
I was playing with Gomez.
And then...
So like...
I was like...
And he was like...
Big mistake.
I have Gomez.
So...
For those who don't know...
Super Gomez is part of Team Sentinels.
And he's like...
One of their...
He's their main...
He's their DPS player.
And then FunFun was like...
Big mistake.
Me have Gomez.
And then I was like...
No, you don't.
Like...
He's on my team.
And he's like...
No, you wrong.
And then...
Obviously...
Um...
He...
And then...
And then like...
He lost.
And he was like...
He was like...
Um...
And then...
I was like...
FunFun put on cheer voice like...
No.
And...
And then...
Honestly...
And then like...
The second time...
And then we got against him again.
I got...
And then...
I got against him...
Again.
And then...
I was like...
Bad thing.
I kept being like...
Because I wanted to teach him a lesson.
I was like...
Just put on streamer mode FunFun.
Just like...
I have on streamer mode now.
Um...
And then...
I was like...
Put on streamer mode.
And then he was like...
Who?
Who is it?
And then I was like...
And then I just wrote...
And then he was like...
Who is it?
And then I was like...
Gomez.
And then he was like...
Oh, I see.
And then he...
And then FunFun...
Bad Starlord.
And I was like...
Oh, I see.
And then Starlord was bad.
Because like...
Gomez is a Starlord.
One trick.
And then Gomez was like...
What the fuck?
Like...
What the...
Why are you trying to...
Bad me?
Of course you...
Why did he trust you?
So...
Okay...
Um...
And...
So...
Um...
And then...
So...
After that...
I was like...
I can't...
I can't keep playing against FunFun.
And...
Cause he's actually an incredibly...
Good tank.
And so like...
Cause he can play any tank and support.
So I was like...
I was like...
Oh, fuck.
We...
Just bring him in.
I was like...
At that point...
I was the only one target banning him.
Because...
We were playing so late...
That the people who recognized FunFun...
Weren't online anymore.
So I was like...
Okay...
Because they're not online...
I was...
I was literally the only one that was target banning him at that point.
So I was like...
Fuck it.
We...
We add...
We add him to the stack.
And then...
And then he was like...
Hi.
He was like...
Thank you for carrying.
And then...
He was just like...
He just came in.
I was like...
Thank you for carry.
And then...
He can't beat him.
He's so...
Everybody wins.
Oh, FunFun.
I love Korean players.
You're so fucking funny.
It reminds me of like...
The times I played a Korean players in...
In Overwatch.
Oh, and then...
It was so...
So...
Because...
His first game with us...
Nobody banned the thing.
But someone in our lobby...
DC...
And then FunFun was like...
Why me?
Chat is like...
No.
Why me?
And then...
We're like...
We're sorry.
FunFun.
But the thing was not banned.
And then we saw it not banned.
And FunFun was like...
Oh my...
It's like...
OMG.
Me...
I get to play.
And then...
In the moment he typed that...
Someone in our team...
DCed on character select.
Poor FunFun.
It was so close.
Poor guy.
Pain, pain and sad.
Sad.
The time...
Actually...
Unfortunate.
Bro, it was crazy.
I was like...
How is that possible?
Our first game as a stack.
And he gets to play the thing.
And then someone left.
Just someone had to leave on our team.
It was like insane.
Obviously, the match got cancelled too.
After...
Because like...
If you leave before the game starts...
Within a minute...
The match just gets cancelled.
And then...
That was insane that that happened.
Anyway, I need to get...
Tissues real quick.
I didn't realize.
I ran out of tissues.
Give me a sec.
I'm going to grab a new box.
I'm doing my job.
Alright.
I'm back.
Sorry, it was like next to me.
Not next to me.
It was outside my door.
That was like...
My adventures.
In the actual...
Like...
At one point...
I played against...
The best team in China.
Like, they were four stacking.
And like...
They were four stacking on the enemy team.
I had to play against the best like...
Marble Rivals team in China.
And then after that...
We were like...
Take off West Coast.
Because they were obviously...
They were playing on West Coast server.
No, we did not fucking win.
With a bunch of random...
NA Crayon Eaters.
No, we...
At like...
Five in the...
Do you really think...
A bunch of random NA players...
At five in the morning...
Um...
At five in the fucking morning...
Be able to beat against a four stack...
Of the best...
China team...
Or Marble...
Yes.
They could...
We were at five...
Guys, players you meet at five AM...
Are not...
Should not be real.
Like...
There is a reason why we're all playing...
At five in the morning, guys.
Like, we are at that point...
We are not real people at that point.
We are like...
The bottom of society...
At that time.
Those aren't people anymore.
Um...
But yes...
And then like...
Yeah, so like...
And then...
So we had to play against those people...
At five...
At five in the morning.
I was like...
Yeah, I'm...
I'm dodging...
The fucking rank one team in China.
Like...
Like, they absolutely destroyed us.
We are not...
People at five AM...
Are not coordinating them...
To even like...
Be a pro...
Like, to even think as a collective.
With...
And pass the first grade.
Like...
Like, they are way too good.
So we like...
Dodged them and stuff.
Um...
Anyway...
No...
Yeah, we had zero brain cells to share at that point.
What do you mean?
I'm saying like...
There was no way we could beat them.
They were so good!
And then like...
What's even funny...
Was that...
Right after...
Being...
Fucking absolutely demolished us...
They messaged...
Like, one of the members in that team...
Messaged Gomez...
And was like...
Can we scrim, you guys?
After...
They were like...
Can we like...
Arrange a scrim with your...
With Team Sentinels later?
I was just like...
Oh my god...
That's so fucking...
Get farmed!
Anyway...
Hey, can we scrim, you guys?
Later?
Love the title.
Nice reference.
Thank you, Frango...
For the Akasupa.
Thank you.
No, no...
It wasn't sent...
Not with the fucking...
5 AM...
More...
Crayon Eater Q.
No, I meant...
I meant the actual Team Sentinels.
I meant...
Anyway...
So yeah, that was like...
That was my 15 hour adventure...
Yesterday...
Night to morning.
I went to bed at like...
I think 8 in the morning.
I went to...
I went to bed at...
Okay, at one point...
We were encountering people who had no idea who Sentinels...
Like...
I...
Like, cause you know...
They're not real people at that point.
So we were running into people who like...
Don't know who like...
Gomez is.
Cause like...
The Sentinels are...
Is really well known...
In Marvel Rivals.
And they're like...
Currently the...
Rank 1 team...
At the moment.
Because of like...
Based off of like...
Winnings and stuff.
So we were...
So like...
We had one guy...
That was shouting slurs...
At...
Cause like...
We were asking him to swap off Hulk.
The Celestial 1 player.
We were like...
Could you swap off Hulk?
Because...
You know...
It's not working.
And obviously I wasn't saying that...
Because I'm a woman.
And I didn't want to get...
I was...
I'm afraid of saying...
Like...
I'm afraid to be confrontational...
In a rank lobby.
Especially...
During really late hours.
Because...
I...
Have no idea...
What people will say to me...
During those incredibly late hours.
Because at that point...
There's no rules...
At that point.
Like...
There's...
No more rules...
At that point.
So like...
I was like...
Hey can you...
Like...
So Gomez was like...
Hey can you swap off Hulk?
It's like...
Not working.
But he said it a little ruder.
And then...
And then the Hulk player...
Started like...
Saying slurs...
At him.
And then I straight up was like...
And saying like...
I'm carrying you.
Like...
You're so fucking bad.
And then...
Insert slurs randomly in that sentence.
And then I...
I straight up...
Talked in my mic.
And was like...
You don't know who Gomez is, do you?
Because he has like...
Hulk was like...
Celestial what?
And then the other team...
The other...
Someone in my team...
Was like...
You know this guy is sad, right?
And then...
And then the Hulk player was like...
Oh fuck...
Oh...
Um...
He was like...
And then the Hulk player was like...
Oh...
Um...
Like he started like...
Fumbling...
He started fumbling...
And then...
And then I'm just like...
Okay...
Guy backed down so fast...
And then he started like...
Sucking up to Gomez...
And was like...
Oh so like...
How much do you get paid?
Um...
And then like...
Oh man...
Like what's it like to be insensitive?
By the way...
He still didn't swap off Hulk...
After the entire thing...
He still didn't...
Swap off Hulk...
We lost by the way...
We...
Even after he started sucking up...
Um...
Look at...
Yeah...
But at least he stopped saying slurs though...
Like...
You know...
You know like...
Baby steps guys...
He stopped slurring at us...
So at least that worked out...
Um...
No 100% I avoided him...
It's just...
You know...
One step at a...
I guess...
Yeah...
That's a plus...
Baby steps guys...
For...
Baby...
Baby steps...
Um...
Oh yeah...
So anyway...
That was my adventures in...
Marvel Rivals...
I'm sorry...
I talked about Rivals for 33 minutes...
But I was also stuck in...
Rivals Jail for 15 hours...
So you can tell why...
My mind...
Is like...
So fixated...
I was...
I was stuck there...
I got stuck there for a while...
I'mma play...
Oh Jesus...
Anyway...
Other than that...
Alright...
Other life updates...
So let's give you a...
I'll give you a dad story...
Guys...
Um...
It's a really short one...
But basically...
Um...
So like...
You know how I always say like...
He loves women?
So like...
Today...
Like not today...
Sorry a couple of days ago...
Um...
You know...
I was taking him to...
Walkies!
Yes, Doki and Badoosh!
Woo!
Walkies!
I love walkies!
But it's late at night, as always, cause like, I do like, late night walks and like, afternoon walks for him.
And... when I went to the elevator, um...
(*coughs*) There was a bunch of guys that, you know, like, I don't know, early 20s.
I can't tell age anymore.
Um, but early 20s guys, just in the elevator.
And all the guys were like, Aw!
Like, let's get, like, they wanted to like, interact with him.
And then dad looked at them, and he was like, (*barking*) And then he was like, You're not a woman!
Don't touch me!
(*laughing*) He wouldn't even let them touch him!
He was like, he was like, barking at him, he was like, Meh!
(*laughing*) He like, looked at them, sniffed them, sniffed, like, Because they all put their hands out for them to, like, smell.
And then he, like, sniffed the hand, and then he, instantly, the switch turned on, and he's like, Not woman.
(*laughing*) He just, he just started barking at them.
And then the thing is, I was like, I'm sorry, and he's like, it's okay.
(*laughing*) And then, like, one of the guys is like, it's okay, it's because he's ugly.
And then I was like, no, like, to his friend, it's because my friend's ugly, isn't it?
And then I was just like, I'm like, I'm sorry.
(*laughing*) And then, and then, like, and then I took him out of the elevator, and then this little fucker, Like, you know, I was like, come on, let's go, let's go.
And then, like, I was walking to the lobby, like, walking to the lobby, to the door, And then, like, he looked back at them, and continued to bark at them.
And was like, be gone, man!
(*laughing*) He was like, nah, woman, be gone!
Like, he looked at them, and was still barking at them, while I was taking us to the fucking door!
(*laughing*) Keep walking!
And he's like, nah, woman, leave!
And then I was just like, please.
And then, like, I went to the door, like, I was outside.
And he was still looking at them!
He kept, like, looking back as we walked, because he was just like, I can't believe they tried to touch me!
(*laughing*) I was just like, Jesus fucking Christ!
If it was women in the elevator, he would be all over them.
He'd be like, ooh, touch me!
Be happy!
(*laughing*) He can be the only man in the area.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I wonder if dad has ever met a man with long hair.
It'd be really funny if that's the only way for him to interact with a man.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Um, yeah, so, yeah, I don't know what, I don't know, I don't know how he became like that.
Um, because, like, he loves, he loves my dad.
So, like, I don't know why he hates men in general.
So, I don't know how he just turned into that.
(*laughing*) Also, like, okay, so, also a very quick thing.
I was so sad because on Sunday, I had the cleaning ladies came in, and I was so happy.
I was like, I'm gonna be productive today!
And then, I'll talk about the cleaning, not situation, it was a great day.
Um, and then I was like, on Sunday, I was like, yippee!
I feel so productive!
I'm gonna go outside and get, uh, dad's nails done.
Because, like, um, because it was getting too long.
And I'm gonna treat him to a nice day at the groomers for the drop-in service.
And then, there's like two, and then I went to two different groomers.
And they were like, and I walked there, by the way.
I fucking walked there, that's a lot for me.
(*laughing*) As someone that works at home, as their job, I walked to a place specifically for my dog.
And then, I was like, and then they're like, sorry, the groomer is closed, like, it doesn't drop by on Sunday.
And I was so fucking sad.
I was like, I was like, going outside, never be productive again.
I was just, in my head, I was like, being, being productive was a mistake.
(*laughing*) I was like, can't believe that one day, I felt so good to go outside, and walked uphill to two different groomers.
And I got told that I should come tomorrow, which was Monday.
And I did go on Monday, because his nails was getting way too long, so I was just like...
But on Monday, I didn't enjoy it.
On Sunday, I was going to enjoy it, because I was like, yippee, I feel so good about myself.
Let me go outside and get fresh air.
And then, it like, justified my excuse to never go outside again.
(*laughing*) I still go outside.
No, I'm just joking, guys.
I still go outside.
But, there's more evidence, right now, to me, on why going outside is bad.
Because nothing good ever happens when you go outside.
(*laughing*)
And I fucking hate Mondays, too.
Uh, no name, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Rookie mistake, she should have been playing Rivals, instead of being productive.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Okay, now we actually play the game.
Sorry, we had a 40 minute tangent here.
Um, it was, a lot of stuff happened in the last two days, guys.
(*laughing*) Anyway, we're playing Cheaters Cheetah.
And I'm also giving away, oh my gosh, wait, I just stopped moving.
What the fuck happened?
(*laughing*) Wait, what the fuck happened?
I just, I just stopped moving.
I booted up my game, and then everything just stopped.
Oh, oh no.
Oh, where did my Steam go?
Wait, did my Steam crash while I was trying to boot up this game?
Oh, my Steam did crash.
Wait, what the fuck?
(*laughing*) What the fuck?
Oh, wait, okay.
Oh, wait, this didn't crash, that's weird.
Okay, wait, give me a sec, let me...
Well, this definitely crashed, so I gotta reboot that.
Uh, whoa, what the fuck is going on?
(*laughing*) Hi Doki, I'm glad that you're finally playing Counter-Strike 2.
Here's 10 dollars to open a few crates and maybe get a super knife.
Red, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Alright, for those who don't know what Cheaters Cheetah is, it is, um, basically, uh, apparently, um, they worked with a cheating, cheat developer to make this game, which is really fucking crazy if you think about it.
The fact that they worked with an actual, um...
Wait, okay, let's see, connecting.
Hello?
Are you connecting?
Oh, no, my... yeah, no, it's definitely, definitely crashed.
Okay.
(*laughing*) But it actually worked, yeah, they actually worked with a hack developer to make this.
So it's basically a game where, like, everybody is cheating, and if you're not cheating, you get banned.
(*laughing*) Like, what the fuck?
That's such a crazy concept.
And, like, and then, so, like, it's whoever cheats the fastest.
So I feel like it's just gonna be, like, super fucking chaotic.
Cause, like, if everybody's cheating, then who the fuck is winning?
(*laughing*) We're finally gonna play the game, her PC.
No, Lord Pancake, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, my PC was like, yeah, no, we're not playing the game yet today.
Alright, let's see, does it work now?
Oh, yeah, there we go.
Nice, okay, I'm okay now.
Let me put, let me boot up Cheater's Cheetah again.
Okay, now it works.
What the fuck?
That was so weird.
It, like, actually, like, crashed for some fucking reason.
Okay, Cheater's Cheetah.
Whoa, I'm in.
Instantly.
Okay.
Alright.
I mean, that was fast, I did not expect- Alright, also, I'm giving away, like...
Um, I believe I'm giving away...
Two game codes.
Also, let me know if they work, because the first code they gave me was already claimed.
By the way, the developers of Cheater's Cheetah reached out to me when I first tweeted about the game, and they gave me free game codes.
But, like, the first code was already claimed by somebody else, so I was like, that's okay.
That's fucking weird.
And so, like, but the second code worked.
So I do have two more codes, but I don't know if they've already been claimed.
Like, I don't know if they, like, accidentally, like, double-booked, like, codes or something to other people, and were like, oh, these codes are definitely not claimed.
You should...
So, like, so, like, whoever wins it, please tell me if it works or not, because I don't, I don't fucking know anymore.
Alright, let's see.
Press insert to open the cheat menu and turn on wallhacks.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that actually...
Oh, rage.
Rage.
Okay, wallhack.
Oh, my God, wait, can I like...
Okay, I can't.
Oh, shit, wait, I can.
I can wallbang.
Oh, my God, I'm playing CS right now.
Wait, what is wallbangable?
No, this isn't wallbangable.
Oh, my...
Wait, is this what it's like?
Oh, my God, is this what it's like?
Now I know why people cheat.
It's that easy?
Oh, my God, it's just that easy.
Who would've thought?
Okay, let's put it on fullscreen, though.
Excuse me, I'm playing a shooter.
I want all the frames.
Clara!
Sorry, guys.
Clara had control of my game a little bit.
Guys, okay, bring down the master volume.
Let me know if it's better.
All right, you know...
Why do I even give a crap about crosshair?
Like, I'm cheating anyway.
I'm like, wait a minute.
I should not care about crosshairs if I'm already cheating.
Is this wallbang?
Yeah.
Okay.
Is this wallbangable?
I don't know what is wallbangable.
What is a...
Is this a wallbang?
Oh, shit.
Oops.
Is this a wallbang?
What the fuck?
How do I know?
That's it.
I'm angry.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
How do I get out?
Get me out!
I missed the instruction!
Oh, there we go.
That's it.
I'm angry now.
Wait, there's still one more.
There we go.
Nice.
Well then, you check how well your weapon in the bottom right HUD.
Now, head over and we'll explain...
Wait, how do you check that?
Okay, let's go over there.
Oh, you have to aim at the glass.
Okay, wait.
Settings, audio.
Let's bring down the sound effects to 0.85.
Alright.
Wait, is it?
Yeah.
Insert to open the cheat menu.
Okay, turn on aimbot.
See that little circle?
The aimbot will automatically lock onto the area.
There we go.
Now, it'll lock into everything.
Jesus Christ!
Oh my God!
Stop installing hacks on my screen!
Whoa!
Oh, and the winner of the match gets the legendary banhammer.
Why the fuck would you ever, like...
Why the fuck would you ever, like, put Hokkaido Apex...
Yay!
God, you've gone too far.
Is cheating really this fun?
I might just hop onto it.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see here.
Play tutorial, open cheat menu.
Like, why the fuck would you ever turn this down?
Like, you're just like, you know what?
I wanna actually use...
Who the fuck uses skill?
Like, what the fuck?
Like, why would you ever turn this lower?
Like, to hide that you're cheating.
Everyone's cheating!
What do you mean...
Okay.
Wait, can I actually do, like, multiplayer?
Solo play.
Wait, I can actually, like...
Wait, semi-rage?
Okay, let's do normal.
I still wanna feel good about myself.
Alright.
Am I trying to play this game?
That's what I'm saying!
I was like, why would you ever play this game?
One...
Bring it back.
Oh no.
Oh...
Guys, I don't wanna spin no more.
I'll just be here.
I'll just be here, guys.
Don't worry!
What are they gonna do?
Oh, kill me!
Okay.
Okay, they're just gonna kill me.
Okay, that makes sense.
Wait.
Wait, okay.
Open cheat menu.
Oh shit.
Okay, don't worry.
I got it.
Don't worry.
I just have to reload.
Oh my...
No!
Wait.
I know what it is.
There we go.
Guys, it's cause I...
My biggest issue was that I had to reload, guys.
That was the...
That was my biggest problem.
I have superior firepower now.
Look at that.
Easy.
Where's the cheat for infinite?
There we go.
Oh my god.
This is so easy.
Look.
Oh man.
Imagine having fucking...
Imagine having to reload, guys.
Imagine that.
This is real firepower.
Hey.
You know what?
I think I can fight real hackers now.
After that.
I'm pretty sure I'm...
Guys, I think I'm good enough to fight real hackers.
100% accuracy.
Yeah!
She's so good.
Wait, this is just normal CS.
Let's go.
A 75 kills streak.
Get out of here.
That's fucking right.
Leave.
That's right.
I'm the biggest cheater around.
The cheetah cheetah.
Yeah.
I will be like her when I grow...
What the fuck?
Okay, wait.
Let me look at my...
Let me open my cheat menu.
Advanced...
What the fuck?
Okay.
Alright.
What the fuck?
What am I gonna do with all of this grenade prediction?
Show bounce.
Wait, I can predict grenades?
What?
Wait, what?
Head, body, enable hitbox, enable multipoint.
Oh my god.
Is this what it's like to have silent aim?
You won't be able to hear the power.
Oh, that's like when you don't hear like the aimbot.
Oh, I can't do enable.
Oh, I can.
So, like, you see where I'm hitting.
But, like, why would you ever hit anything but the...
Okay, so if you're, like, trying to pretend you're not a hacker, you turn on body.
So, like, you turn on body and then multipoint.
So, like, you can try to aim for the head.
Or you do, like, center mass.
Or, like, this is actually with, like, um...
It makes it so that you can fake it type deal.
You're fake aimbotting if you're...
Welcome back.
Close enough.
Welcome back, ToteKing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So, like, the thing is, a lot of people do this in Apex.
How do you know this?
Because I found out one of my acquaintances, like a mutual friend, like a friend of a friend that I played with.
Was actually an aimbotter.
But I never played rank with him.
I've only...
Like, it was when I already got...
Um, when I was, like, just in my phase.
Um, where I was just, like, playing quick play and stuff like that.
So, like, a friend of my friend...
Um, my friend told me, it's like, do you remember this guy that you played with?
And, like, um, that, like, that you played with in quick play?
And I was like, yeah.
And he's like, oh, yeah.
So, I played with him in rank.
And then, like, I found out that he was actually a hacker, like an aimbotter.
And then, but, like, they, like, fake it.
Like, they try to pretend that it's natural aim and everything.
And then they, like, showed, like, like the...
Like, they showed him the aimbot, like, cheat and stuff.
And I was like, what the fuck?
Wait, that guy?
And he's like, oh, yeah.
And then, like, he was, like, naming...
And he, like, that guy, the mutual friend of a friend...
Exposed to him all the people that he knew and played with that were actually secretly hacking.
And it was...
And they used to be legit, too.
They used to be, like, Pred players.
I mean, they aren't Pred players.
But then they're, like...
But then, like...
Obviously, like, people got better.
And, like, other people started hacking.
So then these Pred players were like, well, if everybody else is hacking, I might as well start hacking, too.
So, like, this is an apex.
And then I was like, wait, like, these...
And then he started naming names.
And so I was like, oh, yeah, this guy, this guy, this guy.
They're all, like, actually walling and stuff.
They're all, like, walling.
Or, like, using, like, um...
Um, really...
Like, aimbot where it was, like, very subtle.
But you can still get away with it if you have, like, an...
If you actually have good aim with aimbot, it's so fucking hard to, like, catch them.
So, like, there's, like, a bunch of, like, players.
I don't know.
They're not...
They might not even be playing anymore.
But there used to be, like, a bunch of, like, Pred players in the leaderboards that were just secretly hacking.
And, like, um...
Or, like, walling.
Because, like, you can't get caught when walling.
Um, it's very hard to get caught if you're using wallhacks.
Because the only way to get caught using wallhacks is if someone racks you out.
Or, like, if you're being really fucking stupid with it.
So...
So, like, there's a lot of players out there that are actually secretly wallers.
Or, like, with, like, really...
Or have, like, really good aimbot.
Because if you're really already a really good player...
Um...
It's, um, so hard to get caught.
Are you aimbotting?
Bro, I play Luna Snow!
If I was already...
If I was secretly hacking, I'd be playing Adam Warlock.
I would not be fucking playing Luna Snow.
The lowest DPS for a healer in the game.
Well, that's not true.
There's still, like, two.
But you get what I mean.
Why the fuck would I aimbot on Luna Snow?
Her DPS is so fucking shit.
I would be DPSing as either Mantis or Adam if I was secretly hacking, guys.
Uh...
Oh, yeah.
There's Raccoon.
But I'd rather chop off my fucking hands and play Raccoon.
Alright.
What the fuck is this?
Show behind walls?
Model?
The fuck is that?
Cham?
I am not a hacker to realize what the fuck any of these things mean.
What the fuck do any of these things mean?
What?
What now?
You gotta calm down.
Bro, it's just a game.
It's not just a game.
It's life.
Alright.
Pick and raid.
Do we have anybody here that has cheetahs?
Cheetah?
Alright, I'm gonna host a game.
Um...
Turn off your cheats.
We fight like men.
We are not playing VC.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'm in the dookie.
Guys, I swear to God.
I'm...
Oh my God, is that what it looks like?
Wait.
That's what...
Oh, that's like the grenade projector.
That's right.
Turn off your cheats, bitch.
Oh, okay.
Nice fight.
That's fucking right.
Oh, wait.
Nothing works.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
We fucking...
Turn off your cheats, guys.
No cheats allowed except for...
You know that?
That's...
That's the...
Yeah, that's like the predicted...
Guys, I'm sorry.
Guys, guys, no cheats allowed, guys.
This is a real game now.
We're gonna play...
Oh my God, wait.
Do I have like...
Okay, let's see.
Enable hitbox.
Okay, let's do the baby mode because I can't...
I cannot deal...
Wait.
We're CSing now.
We're CSing free.
We're gonna...
No cheats all night.
Alright, first round is knife round, guys.
First round is always knife round.
This is knife round chat.
Don't worry.
They don't know I have third-person mode on.
They won't know.
I'm the CS crowd.
I was like, you're right.
I could give up...
You know what?
I'll give up two codes right now since we're here.
Alright, guys.
I'm just gonna post it in chat.
Get ready.
Let me know if these codes work because I don't know.
Alright, guys.
Ready?
Since we're playing together.
Alright.
Here's the first code.
Just out of nowhere.
Just...
Anyway.
Huge shoutout to Cheaters Cheetah for giving me codes.
Just like that.
Yeah.
There you go.
Here's the code.
And then here's another code too.
Oh, it worked.
Nice.
Alright.
Now people can join in.
Do we have...
Do we have ten yet?
Guys, where's my...
Where's my cheaters?
No cheats, by the way, guys.
No cheats.
Oh, wait.
I can do team deathmatch kill confirmed.
Let's do like...
Wait.
Sniper only?
Oh, shit.
Wait.
I mean, everyone...
Does it really matter if it's one shot?
Let's do team deathmatch.
Do we do team deathmatch or what's rage?
One cheater on rage.
Oh, wait.
There's legit...
There's raid one cheater on rage mode versus...
That's me.
That...
One person and it's gonna be me.
That's right.
No cheats allowed.
We need three more.
We need three.
Don't cheat, please.
I hold all the power now.
It's only fair, guys.
It's...
Wait.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Alright.
Raid bot.
One versus...
What the fuck?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa.
I thought turn up VC.
Wait a minute.
Voice chat off.
Okay.
One versus...
Oh, my God.
They're throwing grenades.
That's cheating.
I think he was saying dick.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
What?
How are they getting me?
That's insane.
Oh, no.
They're just throwing grenades.
No.
That's not fair.
They have to be cheating, too.
How are they doing this?
What?
Oh,
my God.
What the fuck?
I'm trying my best.
Where's my mini gun?
Okay.
That's...
That's enough.
I'm mad.
I'm mad now.
Oh, shit.
He knows I'm reloading.
I'm mad now.
Get over here.
I'm so mad.
No.
That's it.
This is not fair.
They're using utilities like actual players against actors.
They're using utilities.
That's not fair.
Oh, no.
They're using you, too.
I can't believe it.
Oh, my God.
Not you, too.
No, I got it.
Oh, my God.
Get out.
Oh, shit.
I can't believe it.
That's it.
I'm actually angry now.
Oh, my God.
Wait, no.
That's way too angry.
Oh, my God.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
There's too many.
Oh, my God.
There's too many of you.
I thought there were ten.
There's not ten people.
There's no way to send.
There's no...
Utilities.
No.
Not the you, too.
Oh, my God.
Here.
What?
No, get me out.
No.
Oh, my God.
That's not fair.
What?
I thought you guys...
I don't understand.
I had aim.
How did I lose?
Cheaters never win, doggy.
How did I...
How did I lose?
Okay, wait.
I'm the one rage cheater.
It's not fair.
This is actually not fair.
Also, what the fuck was that guy saying?
Was he saying dick?
Was he just being like dick, dick, dick, dick?
All I heard was dick.
I hope he wasn't slurring.
I hope he...
Okay.
Okay, I was like...
I was like...
I hope he was not slurring.
I thought he was saying dick.
It was joking.
Thank God.
I was like, I hope guys...
I was like...
Okay.
Alright.
So, like...
That didn't work, guys.
That...
Guys, that...
That didn't work.
So, let me just...
You know what?
Let's just make it...
We all start cheating, guys.
Yeah.
Let's just all start cheating, everybody.
Let's all just...
Guys, guys.
Let's just all start cheating.
Yeah.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe they use u-tilt like a fucking nerd.
Fucking try...
Oh my God.
I knew you guys are CS players.
Goddamn CS players in my lobbies.
Using fucking u-tilt.
Nerds.
All of you.
Fucking nerds.
Oh my God.
You cheated not only the game, but yourself.
You didn't grow.
You didn't improve.
You took a shortcut and gained nothing.
You experienced a hollow victory.
No, not even a victory.
A hollow...
No!
Dad!
Stop!
Stop shaming me!
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Please!
Stop shaming me!
Stop!
No!
Don't shame me!
Alright, we need one more person.
Oh, fuck it.
Let's just...
One team just isn't gonna have...
One team just isn't gonna have ten players.
Or five players.
Stop!
Alright.
Oh my God.
Alright, we need a third person.
The spin.
Okay.
Nice!
Wait, that's my teammate.
That's right.
This is how you make your aimbot natural.
Oh my God.
Not the u-tail!
This guy is going fucking crazy.
This guy.
Woah.
That's right.
I'm gonna...
That's actually right.
I know how to fucking fight a...
Oh!
Bitch.
The pink tip.
Lies.
I'm just that good.
You know what?
Fuck you guys and your stupid u-tail.
Fuck you guys.
Oh shit.
Okay, nice.
Just start jiggle peeking.
Just start jiggle...
Oh my God.
There you go.
That's a good aim.
Oh my God.
Look.
Oh.
Woah.
Oh shit.
I'm insane.
Oh no!
God.
The jiggle.
Oh shit.
He's sitting so fast.
Holy fuck.
The jiggle peeking.
That's right.
This is how you actually aimbot, guys.
For real.
Oh wait.
That's my teammate.
I was like, why am I aimbot not working?
Oh my God.
Look at him go.
Oh no!
God.
Spin.
Oh my God.
Okay, guys.
I gotta...
Wait.
What am I using?
Oh my God.
The AWP.
Come on.
Peek me.
Oh my God.
Wait.
Come on.
Holy shit.
Oh my God.
Are you okay?
Oh no.
Oh my God.
He finally left.
Okay.
Wait.
What's the SM?
Okay.
No more AWPing.
He saw an opportunity.
Oh, it'll be so fun with walls with an AWP.
Spun too much.
You spun too much.
That's right.
This is how you actually start hacking.
Use the walls to your advantage.
Oh, you're right.
The sniper mode will go so fucking hard.
You're so right.
Come on.
Oh.
That's right.
Tack this, bitch.
No, shit.
Not the nades.
Oh, fuck.
God.
There's everywhere.
That's fucked up.
Professional cheater.
That's right.
I played with enough hackers to know how to hack a hacker.
What's happening?
Guys, if I go to spin mode, you guys are going to get fucking most...
Wait, actually...
Wait, if I do third person spin mode, maybe?
Third person.
Wait.
Oh, shit.
Wait, what the fuck?
I'll make it go faster.
I will make my spin go faster.
Wait, how did it go so fast?
That's fucking...
I'm ready.
I'm fucking spin.
How does he go so fast?
I don't understand.
Wait, okay.
Miss.
Bounce.
Show.
Guys, I want to spin just as fast.
Spin to win.
He's just better.
Wait.
Rage tab?
No, it just says spin.
I can't spin any faster.
Wait, there's rage advance?
Where's the rage advance?
Teammate.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
What is pitch?
I'm ready.
That's right.
That's a god fucking rage.
No!
How was he off it?
Bro!
How the fuck are you off it?
Oh, no.
Oh, we win!
Let's go!
Where is your god now?
Where is he now?
No!
I wanted to be better.
When you're out of adderall.
There we go.
We did it, guys.
I did it, guys.
I won.
On me.
Rotation.
I was throwing Fortnite.
Okay, so thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, guys.
Okay.
So, let's do...
Oh, okay.
Let's actually...
Let's do like...
Oh, let's do legit sniper only.
I wanna see how you guys do that.
Let's do legit sniper only, guys.
We're playing real now.
All we have is wallhacks, guys.
Wait, I should have to do my...
Wait, now I know why.
You have to do your crosshair.
Now I know why.
Guys, wait.
Wait, let me actually have a good...
Okay, show, set, don't show.
Okay.
Guys, wait.
Wait, guys.
I actually have to find my crosshair.
Give me a sec.
I actually have to figure out my crosshair.
Here we go.
Guys.
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to figure out my crosshair right now.
Okay.
Here we go.
Now we have real aim.
There we go.
Now I'm good.
Now I'm good, guys.
Alright.
Come on.
Oh, he's scared.
Let's move over here.
Come on.
You little bitch.
You're such a little...
Wow, just...
That's a Q, right?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Real aim time.
That's right.
Oh, shit.
That's a Q, right?
That's right.
This is how you actually hack.
Oh, you missed, little baby.
You missed, little boy.
You missed.
Missed.
You missed again.
No.
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh, fuck.
I missed too.
There we go.
I don't miss this.
No.
I missed.
It's not fair.
This is not fair.
Bro, he's fucking...
He's fucking body hopping.
You fucker.
You try hard.
You're actually...
Bro, he has CS.
He has CS movement.
How?
That's a Q, right?
Like, how do you have CS movement?
I turned everything off.
Everything's off.
Oh, my God.
My aimbot keeps going on and off because I forgot to turn it off.
It's not working.
My aimbot.
I can't believe.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Oh, my God.
I better...
I have actual aimers on my team.
Oh, my God.
They're not...
They're all not compensating for something, guys.
Is that crazy?
Jesus.
That's fucking...
No.
Oh, my God.
That's fine.
No.
Fucking...
It's so...
They're like...
That's crazy.
I don't wanna fucking shoot him anymore.
Oh, my God.
They're actually B-hopping the second day.
You still got him.
Jesus.
Oh, my God.
He's trying to...
That's looking right.
Get over here.
Oh, my God.
They're all looking at me.
That's fucking right.
Get off.
Come on.
Stand there.
You know you want to.
No!
I told you.
It's just...
How the fuck do you even do that?
How do you B-hop?
I can't do it.
Well, I can't do it now.
Oh, no.
This is lit.
How the fuck do you B-hop?
I've never B-hopped.
I've never played CS before.
Oh, never mind.
I'm better.
I'm so much better.
Oh, my God.
I can learn this.
I can do this.
I can...
Guys, am I doing it?
Yes.
This is how you do it, guys.
You think I'm doing it?
Wait.
No!
Guys, I'm not doing it.
Guys, I don't...
I am absolutely not doing it, guys.
I am...
Bro!
This is not fair!
It's so fast!
Fast!
No.
No!
This is where I've been joked to death by it, but I'm just catching a stream.
So, I'm not the T.
You're not that guy, Toki.
What a bunch of cheaters.
Oh, my God.
No!
I thought...
I don't know how to B-hop, guys.
I don't know.
No!
Alright, guys.
I'll be right back, guys.
I need to use the bathroom, everybody.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
I'm back, everybody.
I can't believe...
I still think...
I think it's so fucking funny when one of the guys was just B-hopping and my teammate just gave up and just threw a termite at him.
Like, he wasn't even gonna shoot him anymore.
He was...
It's just like...
Fuck that shit!
Okay.
I'm gonna make a new lobby in case there's new dragoons that wanna join.
Alright.
Host match.
Okay.
Oh.
No cheats.
Wait, how do you...
I have it on, but I don't know how to set it.
It says auto B-hop.
How does that work?
How does auto B-hop work?
Don't...
How does that work?
I don't know how it works.
Hold space.
Oh, the hold space bar.
Bro, he's doing it legit.
Bro, what the fuck?
This is actual...
They have actual CS?
Oh my god.
Bro, that guy's doing it legit.
Cause cheats don't work in the lobby.
There's no cheats in the lobby.
He's just that good.
Bro, the lobby has no cheats.
Alright, alright.
Let's do the settings.
Okay, we...
Alright, random.
Alright, what do we wanna try this time?
Okay, what did we do?
We could do King of the Hill.
Oh, King of the Hill might be fun.
King of the Hill.
Alright.
I don't wanna do Raid Boss anymore.
Raid Boss was not it, guys.
Raid...
Guys, Raid Boss was just not it.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, and that...
We'll do another one of the...
We'll do another one of the wallhacks only.
Kill confirm is that after...
Oh my god.
I forgot.
It's time.
It's fucking time.
Advance.
Rage.
Open cheat menu.
Oh, fuck.
This cheat menu is like so overwhelming.
It's time.
Oh my god, I'm doing it, guys.
I'm bun...
Am I bunny hopping?
Guys, am I bunny hopping, guys?
Am I...
Guys, is this bunny hopping?
Guys.
Guys, am I doing it?
Guys, am I...
What?
No, yes I am!
Yes I am!
Please look at me.
Guys, you don't understand.
How do you do it?
I gotta lower the spin.
It's too much.
Okay.
The spin is a little bit too much.
But I'll turn on the pitch.
The knife is so scary, guys.
Guys, I don't think they realize what king of the hill is.
I don't...
I don't think they...
Oh no, he's coming.
He's coming.
Oh no.
That's right.
Can't even get out of spawn.
That's fucking right.
That's easiest win of my life.
They don't know it's king of the hill.
Easiest...
You know what?
I'm gonna drop a u-tail.
Boom.
I don't know where it's going.
Oh shit.
Spin me right around, right around.
Nice u-tail.
Oh no, they figured out the game.
Guys.
They figured out the game, guys.
Oh no.
Don't worry.
Oh my god.
The csgoer is playing.
He's using an AWP.
That fucking cheater.
It's okay.
Okay, no more spin.
Guys, I don't think I'm ready for spin, guys.
I don't...
I don't think I'm ready.
What's silent aim?
Oh, silent aim is making so that it's not like I'm cheating.
But like, what's the point?
I'm raging right now.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
This is fine.
No more spin time.
So you spin out of this.
Guys, he's...
Guys.
Guys, I think he...
Oh, I'm coming for you.
Guys, leave one for me.
Leave him to me.
That's fucking right.
Guys, surround him.
No, I forgot I put the Jackson up in the city.
I didn't realize it was time.
I wanted to get out.
No.
I
didn't realize.
I'm so mad.
No.
Too much BM.
It's not fair.
It's not...
I'm gonna fucking shank you.
Alright, it's time.
Guys.
It's time to play a real game now.
It's legit mode time.
Alright, what is it?
Is it team death?
It should be.
Sniper only.
Oh.
Wait.
Kill confirmed.
Let's do kill confirmed.
Real.
It's real time.
We're doing real game.
One, two.
Guys.
Wait.
Do we have ten?
I don't know if this is like a bug or we do have ten people.
Do we have ten people?
One, two, three, four, five.
Guys.
Stand still, guys.
Everybody in the line.
Every dragoon in the line.
Starting here.
Here.
Follow the square.
Everyone in the line so I can count you all.
Guys.
Everyone in the line.
Stand in the line.
Guys, this is not a fucking line.
Okay.
Start here.
You all get a square.
You all get a square so I can count properly.
All of you.
Stand on your own respective square.
Stand in...
Someone.
Move.
Move to the square.
There's an empty square.
That's right.
Move.
Everybody in their square.
Everybody in your...
Bro.
Move.
Move to this.
That's right.
Alright.
You move here.
And then we're all...
Do we all have a square?
Guys.
Stop.
Move.
Move back to your square.
Guys.
Okay.
Alright.
You.
Move here.
Okay.
One.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Alright.
We're missing one dragoon.
It's like you're eating cat.
Alright.
You guys all stay here.
Guys.
We're missing one more.
We need one more dragoon to join us.
Guys.
Stay in your square, guys.
Don't leave your square.
Stay in your square.
You all...
This is your designated square.
This is a jailbreak.
How do you guys still have util?
I don't even have util anymore.
Alright.
Guys.
Actually, just one person.
Just one person.
One team.
It's not going to be my team.
That's fine.
One team is just not going to have...
One team is just going to have four people instead of five.
And it's not going to be mine.
And they hid it.
Alright.
Here we go.
Guys.
We only have walls.
Wait.
My team is a one with four.
That's...
Wait a minute.
My team is a one with four.
Oh, fuck.
I don't know how to use the off.
I don't know how to use the a.
Wait a minute.
Oh, I forgot.
Wait.
I don't play...
Guys, I'm so...
Oh, shit!
Guys, it's fine.
Guys.
Guys, I don't know how to...
Guys, I don't know how...
Guys, no.
Don't let him talk!
I don't know, I forgot I don't play CS!
Okay, nice.
Oh no, oh no.
Oh no, the Bhopper, he's getting closer.
Guys, okay, cover me.
Cover me guys, I'm going for it.
Cover me.
Oh my god, nice.
Oh my god, he's coming.
Guys, guys, he's Bhopping.
Guys, guys, he's fucking CS surfing right now.
Guys, guys, what if we all knife each other?
It would be so funny.
Guys, how do I, how do I use the AK, guys?
I don't play tactical.
Okay, alright.
It's time.
A real hack aim, a real waller would use a sniper at that point.
Guys, why don't we all just start knifing each other, guys?
Wouldn't that be funny?
No!
Guys, I don't.
Guys, guys, he's coming for me!
Oh shit, I'm fucking gaming.
I'm a gamer.
Wait, what the fuck?
He was gonna knife me.
Oh, that's it, you're it.
Oh, that's right!
Oh shit!
I suck at left knife.
Guys, guys, bring out all your knives, guys.
Guys, we're all gonna start knifing, guys.
Every single one of us!
No!
No,
buddy!
We're all gonna start knifing.
Wait, is that actually Cody?
Is that actually Cody?
Wait, is that?
Oh shit!
Oh, fuck it, there we go, we're good.
We're good, guys.
Okay, what did we all just start?
Okay, actual legit knifing, guys.
It's knifing time.
Guys, it's knifing.
That's it.
Oh, let's go.
Let's go.
We're all gonna...
Let's go, it's knifetime.
Let's go, let's go.
Let's go, I can do this.
Let's go, it's knifetime.
No honor!
No honor if you don't knife!
Get over here!
No!
Knife only!
No honor if you don't knife!
That's fucking right!
Welcome to London!
You're right, Cody.
You're so right.
You're so fucking right.
London simulator right now.
Let's go.
Don't let them get me!
That's so cute.
He's like, fuck you.
Cody doesn't care anymore.
He doesn't care.
He brought a gun to a knife fight.
America.
Don't let them get you!
Knife.
He even brought a gun to London, that's crazy.
Bro, he's so fast!
Get him!
Just kill this one!
You can't fucking run away forever!
Fucking get
him!
He crossed the pie.
Alright, that's the key, right?
That's right, this time.
That's right.
That's right, get out of here.
Get out of here.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
Nice.
Oh shit, okay.
Now that Cody's here, let's do something.
Wait.
Alright, alright, alright.
Let's do actual rage now.
Let's do rage and we'll do a capture the flag.
And then, oh my god, alright.
Capture the- what the fuck is this profile picture?
Wait,
can I actually- oh wait, I can swap teams.
Okay, wait.
I'll put- Wait, how do I switch to random?
Wait, how do I manually swap people?
Oh well, I don't really care that much.
Alright.
Is that- is that like who- who's the fuck?
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Real hacking time.
It's hacking time.
It's time.
Let's capture the flag.
Oh my god, you too.
That's fucking right.
Welcome to you jiggle peeping bitch.
Alright.
Oh my god, Manny, you're fucking- oh no, not the util!
Stupid util, stupid fucking util.
Stupid fucking- Guys, we need to get the flag.
Guys, how we gonna get the flag, guys?
No, the util!
Typical cheaters.
Use a util.
Fight me like a real cheater.
Guns only.
No!
Oh my god.
No one is- because we need to make it to the flag, guys.
How we gonna make it to the flag?
Nice.
That's how.
That's fucking how.
Don't worry, I've got this.
I'll be the hero that you cannot- that you can't be.
Oh my god, they're putting walls up.
They're building walls, guys.
Oh my god, I don't think he knows I'm reloading.
That's fucking right.
Nothing!
I can't believe you would camp.
No honor.
No fucking honor right there.
Oh my god, not the nade.
Not the nade.
No, not two nades.
Not three nades.
No.
I can't believe- you already have hats, why are you camping?
Wait, are flags being taken?
We gotta get our flag back.
Get our flag- wait, what is this?
Okay, got our flag back.
I'm using a new gun.
I don't know if it's better, but it has more bullets.
Okay, it's not better, guys.
Alright, guys, I get it.
It's off time.
Guys, it was definitely not better, guys.
It was definitely not better.
It was not better at all.
Oh my god, stupid util users.
What?!
How am I losing?!
We're all cheating!
No!
Win!
We can't win!
We just need one point!
Wait, they scored?!
They're so good.
Oh my god, wait.
Wait, that's a CS player.
That's a fucking CS player.
No, I almost made it!
I almost made it!
I actually- Oh my god, I saw her bhop.
I saw that person bhop.
They're actual CS players.
That's not fair.
That's actually not fair.
That's- oh my god, they actually play CS!
I saw them bhop.
I can't believe it.
I know they hack in CS.
They know the tech.
Some people actually- Guys, we gotta go in together, guys.
It's right- oh my god, he's a king.
Oh my god, oh my god, he's a king.
Oh my god, he's bad.
He's actually doing it.
He's a guy- No!
We were so close!
It was right there!
Please.
Please, we can tie.
Please, I don't want to get bad hammered.
Please.
Please don't bad hammer me, please.
Please, 20 seconds.
We can do this.
I got one.
Oh, I- Okay, we got two.
No!
The goddammit!
No.
I just gotta hide.
Oh my god, they can't make it.
They won't be able to find me.
Oh, they won't be able to- No, why are you here?
Why are you here?
Oh, no.
No, they're not here.
No, they don't know!
No!
Oh, thank god!
He took me out of my misery.
They know.
They have lost.
Okay, of course.
No, they don't know.
Guys.
I don't know.
I thought that maybe they would know, guys.
I thought that maybe they would know.
I don't know.
I thought maybe I'd be free.
It didn't.
It didn't matter.
Oh, man.
I wish I could make it so I could tell who gets to be the raid boss.
I can assign a raid boss, but I think it goes to Mjolnir.
That was fucked up.
That was so fucked up when it went to me.
Alright, what if we do legit?
Okay, what do we do, guys?
Guys, what do we want?
No, raid boss was not it.
Raid boss was actually not it.
That was so fucked up.
That was so fucked up, guys.
Everyone just... Oh, my God.
Okay, we'll do two.
We'll do two raid bosses, okay?
Alright.
One raid.
Okay.
But how do I make it?
How do I... Okay, I'll do two.
Wait, two raid bosses.
Alright.
I'll do it.
Okay.
He wants it?
Alright.
One versus all.
Well, it's two versus all now.
It's two versus all.
That one versus all was not it.
Oh, he's angry.
Oh, wait.
Who's the boss?
Oh, it's not us.
Guys.
Guys, it's not us.
We are... Oh, guys.
Guys, we gotta use util.
Guys, we gotta use util, guys.
Guys.
Guys, it's not it.
Guys, there's two of them.
It's actually a lot harder now that there's two of them.
Guys.
Guys, we gotta work together, guys.
Use the util, guys.
Guys, use the util.
No!
What are you looking at, huh?
What are you looking at?
Guys, we're not... Guys, we're not making it out of spawn.
Oh, we did it!
Kill them!
Oh, we died.
We died.
I'm trying my best!
Guys, we got it.
Wait, they scored?
Guys, we just lost.
Oh, no.
Guys, how did we lose?
Guys, no!
No!
Oh, they
forgot!
They forgot!
Okay, let's do one.
One.
Guys, we figured it out.
We just have one raid boss.
Guys,
just one raid boss.
Okay, one raid boss and it won't be me.
I hope to God it won't be me, guys.
I cannot be a raid boss again.
I can't.
Please.
Please, I can't do it again.
Okay, we got this.
It's one person.
It's one person, guys.
It's... It's one person.
There's no way.
It's one person.
It's one guy.
He can't get us all.
We'll do it until Coney gets it.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Guys, it's fine.
Guys, it's okay.
There's so many of us.
Guys, there's so many of us.
It's okay.
We got this.
It's one guy.
Guys, guys, don't burn yourself, guys.
I tell Coney I'm gonna do this until he gets raid boss.
That's right.
Let's get him.
Let's fucking get him.
That's the key, right?
Oh, I have...
Oh my god, you can wallbang that?
You can fucking wallbang that?
Yeah, but I got him.
I got him.
Aim botter down.
You can't get the flag now, bitch.
That's right.
All that CS training is not gonna help you now, fucker.
Oh shit.
Oh shit, my one bullet.
My one...
No, my one bullet.
He says no thank you.
No, I want him.
I want an experienced raid boss.
That was so fucked up when I had to do it.
Where the fuck is... Wait, what?
Oh my god, he's just BRB.
Wait, guys, stop it.
He's so... Oh shit.
Bro, what the fuck?
It's just... Guys, we can't let him have the flag.
Guys, bro, he's just...
He's just...
We can't catch him.
Oh no.
Guys, we can't catch him.
He's so fast.
He's just... Oh my god, he's so fast.
Oh my god.
It's not fair.
Where's our other CS player?
Where is he?
Jesus Christ, all he does is B.
Bro, we can't catch him.
Jesus Christ.
It's okay, he can't B-hop forever.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, maybe he can.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
Oh god, he just smacked
home.
Yes, he can.
Oh my god, that's crazy.
Bro, that man almost did it.
He can, in fact, B-hop forever.
Yay.
Yes, we can.
That's crazy.
That guy was the ultimate cheetah.
That guy was actually insane.
Oh my god.
Bro had the strats.
Alright guys, we're gonna do this lobby until Kony gets Rain Boss.
Yeah, he almost won.
That was insane that he almost won.
That's fucking crazy.
It's not so loud, bro.
Thanks.
I turned the timer down.
Alright, two minutes.
Alright.
Alright, Kony.
Wait, did Kony?
No, he's still here.
It's just bugged.
See, he's right here.
I wish we could make it so I could automatically give him Rain Boss.
Alright, let's see if this works.
Alright, let's see if Kony gets it.
That's crazy.
That's not fair.
He has years of CS experience.
No!
Get me out!
How do I end this?
No!
Oh no.
Not again.
No!
Not again!
Oh fuck, not again!
No, I can't do this one!
Oh my god, I need...
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Oh no, get me out of here.
Get me out of this hell.
No!
Get me out!
Wait, I know the strat.
Guys, am I bee hopping?
Wait,
give me a sec.
Guys, give me a sec.
Guys, it's time.
Guys.
Guys, let me, please.
Guys, please.
Guys.
Please!
Here we go.
There we go.
They can't get all of me.
It's fine.
Here we go.
Guys, am I bee hopping?
It's happening!
They trapped me!
No!
I'm trapped!
Stop!
Don't look at me!
Stop looking at me!
Stop!
No!
I got spawned.
Why can't Cody be the rainbow?
It's not fair!
I just want Cody to experience this hell.
Thank you for the super chat.
Give it to Cody!
Why is it always me?
Tell Cody to make the lobby.
No more.
No more funny mode.
Alright.
What do we guys want?
What do we want, guys?
What do we want?
Guys, what should we do next?
Where is one shot?
Legit?
Okay, legit.
All rage?
One shot does not matter.
Everybody.
Sniper...
We did sniper only.
With...
We did sniper only already.
We already did sniper only.
We did all of it, I'm pretty sure.
But do we want legit or...
We can do king of the hill legit.
Or rage.
Do we do rage or king of the hill?
Guys, what do we do?
One shot rage is super fun.
Okay, one shot?
Okay, one shot.
One shot, king of the hill.
One shot, king of the hill or legit king of the hill?
What does Cody want?
Inside the lobby.
What does he want?
I can't believe he's in my lobby.
Okay, we're doing...
It depends on rage.
If it's rage, then I have to be on third person because I can't fucking...
I can't aim bot when I'm like first person.
It just feels so fucking...
He's still learning?
Down for anything?
Alright, we'll do rage, king of the hill.
One shot, random.
How do you learn the game?
He's not learning!
We're all cheating!
What do you mean learn the game?
We're all fucking hacking.
Like, what do you mean?
We're all hacking.
He's ass at cheating.
How do you mean ass at cheating?
Just jiggle peek.
Oh shit.
I fucked up already.
Wait, what?
You use shield?
No!
You too!
You fucking cheater.
He used you too.
Fucking freak.
Oh no.
I already used my one bullet and I double clicked on accident.
I can't believe he...
That's like, you're right, you fucker.
Worth.
They have the actual CS player!
They're here!
They're using you too!
Guys!
F2P!
Are you trying to say he's a better CS player than you, F2P?
Is that what you're trying to say?
Oh wait, no, he's doing it.
He's nerfing them all.
Oh my god, F2P!
Oh my god, okay, F2P!
Put your hacks on!
F2P, put your hacks on!
That's like, you're right, bitch.
Oh my god, fuck, I'm the bitch.
Oh my god.
F2P, you have to...
Put on the gun, it's time!
Be the rock, Lee!
Put down your weights!
It's time to put down the weights, F2P!
And get that gun out!
It's time!
This is the moment you've been waiting for!
That's fucking right, Cody.
That's fucking right.
This is it.
Get that gun!
It's time!
Oh my god, he's doing it!
Oh my god, he's using his 10 plus years of CS!
This is the moment he's been waiting...
Oh my god, go F2P!
Go!
Go be crazy!
That's exactly right!
Oh my god, kill everybody!
Oh shit, oh shit.
I only have a knife now.
No!
1v6 them all!
Oh no, he's dead.
He's cracked.
They have Mama Rin, we have F2P.
The two fucking bhoppers.
Oh no, oh no.
No, F2P!
No, this is not how it's supposed to go!
This is not how it's supposed to go, F2P!
They're getting the...
Oh my god, it's sad.
Oh my god, he's so good.
He's actually so good.
What do I do?
No!
They're gonna do it!
Oh no.
Oh fuck.
He's doing it.
Gotta lock in.
No, he locked in before me!
Oh no.
Oh no, F2P, this is it.
This is your carry, our 1v5!
No!
No, they're in A6!
Oh my god, no!
Oh my god, we got two.
Oh my god, 2P, this is it, this is your character arc.
This is it.
This is it, this is it!
We got it back.
Oh no, it's just me.
Oh no, it's me and Marmorin.
What do I do?
I'm so scared.
He doesn't have bullets.
He doesn't have bullets, I know he doesn't have bullets.
I know he doesn't.
Oh my god, there he is.
Oh my god, they're all spinning.
They're all spinning.
Oh, I don't have bullets either!
I don't have bullets either!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they're just...
Oh shit, oh shit, we gotta get on point.
No!
Protect me!
Get near me!
Get near
me!
You've never played CS...
How are you B-hopping?
I don't understand.
How are you able to do it without...
To be dropped away.
It's not easy!
I don't understand.
That was so close.
We were at 92 to 90 and they...
Okay, the one-shot one is fun.
I think the one-shot one is really fun.
Alright, let's do the...
Let's do...
Okay, when they started...
That was really funny.
When they started just spinning was pretty funny.
Okay.
Do we do capture?
Let's do team deathmatch for legit.
We'll do legit now.
We'll do legit.
How dare you call me a deadweight!
I played very well.
Okay, I...
I played pretty well for someone that never played CS, guys.
I think I did really well.
Also, let me fix the fact that my aimpod keeps turning on and off.
Let me fix that.
Real quick.
Okay, there we go.
There we go, I fixed it.
I was too lazy, but now I'm not lazy anymore.
Alright, here we go.
We'll do legit team deathmatch.
Random.
I got distracted by all the...
all the spins.
All the spinning was a little distracting.
Yeah, okay.
Because it's legit, I don't need to be a first person for this.
Alright.
It's real aimpod time.
Oh, it's over.
I have mamarin.
It's fucking over.
I have a real gamer now.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Burn, yeah, that's right, burn!
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
He's coming, oh no, he's coming.
Guys, shake him, shake him before...
Yeah!
That's a...
Bodyguards.
That's right.
I don't have a bullet.
Thank this person.
Where did he go?
Guys, I need that kill, guys, I need that kill.
I don't have...
No!
I don't have a bullet!
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, he's gonna carry us.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Where was the angle?
Guys, it's okay.
It's okay, they're using util, which is obviously hacking.
What the fuck is he doing?
I can't believe it.
You're a real gamer.
No!
I was doing so well!
Guys, I'm still doing really well.
Drive by Shaq.
That's crazy.
Oh no, that was my kill.
No, oh you missed.
You missed, buddy, you missed.
No, I missed!
God damn it, Cody!
How the fuck do you miss?
Oh fuck.
Oh fuck, okay.
No, I need this bullet, guys, I need...
No, I need the bullet more!
Okay.
I pretend I was shooting.
Guys, guys, there's two...
Okay.
Guys, do you think...
He's so good at shaking!
I don't understand!
Has Cody traveled to London?
Oh my god.
Get him, get him, get him.
Oh no.
Oh, I need...
He doesn't have a gun, he doesn't have a gun.
He doesn't have a gun.
I swear, he's
fucking shaking.
I don't understand.
I just meant to shake.
No!
Okay, it wasn't Cody.
Wait, do I have right click?
Oh my god.
I didn't realize I didn't realize there was a right click.
I'm fast now.
Wait, I think I bhop this time for real.
Does this look like I'm bhopping, guys?
Guys.
No, no!
Wait.
There we go.
Wait, I still have one more bullet.
I still have one more.
Guys, does this look like I'm bhopping?
Wait, look.
Look, why is knife when I can shoot?
Why is knife when I can...
Oh,
god damn it!
Get at this!
Cody, I'm gonna fucking get you!
Ah, Cody, you little whore!
You're such a whore!
I can't!
Guys, leave Cody for me!
Leave him for me, guys!
Don't get Cody!
He's mine!
No!
It was my kill!
Sorry, my kill.
I'll take this one.
It was supposed to be my kill!
He didn't earn it!
Yes, I did!
I did, it was mine!
I did earn it!
Alright.
I think Rage one-shot is definitely more fun.
For sure.
What do we do?
We did legit kill confirmed, right?
Alright, what should we do?
I think King of... Oh, let's do Capture the Flag one-shot.
Yeah, Capture the Flag one-shot.
Alright.
Capture the Flag one-shot.
This would be my...
This is my LG.
Wait, Cody's out?
Oh, Cody's out, but yeah.
This is my LG here.
Alright.
I don't think Capture the Flag one-shot is much more fun.
I think the one-shot mode is definitely a lot more fun.
Okay.
Well, actually, no.
This is not LG.
I'll make one last lap.
No!
Wait, they have Marmorant and F2P!
Guys, we're fucked.
Guys.
Guys, we're not... Guys.
Guys, they have Marmorant and F2P.
Guys.
Guys, they have the Barbie Hoppers.
They have... They have the Barbie Hoppers.
Guys.
Guys, we're...
It's not fair!
They have people who can B-hop!
We can't!
Guys!
Guys, he's just hopping away!
He's just hopping away!
What the fuck do we... He's just...
He's just hopping away.
Bro, he's just...
Oh my god!
No!
He's just hopping!
How did we get him?
I forgot I was aimbotting.
Oh my god!
And he went away.
Boom, boom, boom.
Oh my god, it's not fair!
He's just jumping.
He's just jumping so fast!
Like, what do we do?
This is like...
Like, he's jumping!
They have two B-hoppers?
What do we do?
He's just jumping!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, bro, he's jumping again!
What the fuck?
He's just...
He's just jumping away!
What do we do?
I don't know, what the fuck do we do?
Oh my god, guys, help me!
Guys!
Guys, help me!
Oh my god, we got a boy!
Guys, I'm so proud of us!
I'm so proud of us!
We got a boy, everybody!
We did it!
We got one!
Please don't be disappointed in me!
Please don't be disappointed, I know!
I know, he's just hopping away!
I don't know what to do, Jokey!
I don't know what to do, he's just hopping!
He's just He's just...
Stop shaving me!
He's shaving me!
Oh my god, he's just shaving me!
I can't believe it!
Please have mercy!
It's not fair!
Look at him!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I finally got one of the bee hoppers, guys!
The world is safe now!
Do not worry!
The world is now safe!
Oh my god, worry!
Worry!
Oh my god!
Guys, if you...
How do I... Guys, how do I win this?
Guys, look at them!
They're just...
Just let them take it!
End this misery!
Just let them take it, guys!
Just let them come in, and bee hop away, and take the flag, and then bee hop away!
Not sure...
You don't win, you survive!
Guys, form a circle around me, guys!
We know we lost, guys!
Just form a circle around me, protect me!
Protect me in this corner, guys!
Protect me before it's too late!
Guys, protect me in this corner!
Guys, get over here!
Get over here, protect me!
And we all bunched up together, they don't know which one's me!
They won't know which one's me!
And we all bunched up together!
Which one's the real dookie?
They won't know!
That's right!
Yay, I survived!
They couldn't tell!
I survived!
Okay, we'll do one last, we'll make a new lobby and do one last game, guys.
We'll make a new lobby and I'll do one last game.
Dad knows!
It worked!
It worked, everyone!
Aw, jeez!
Alright, I think he's hungry.
I'll go get him food, too.
I'll be right back.
Yeah, he was hungry.
He was like, food time!
And then the moment I put food on the on the tree, he's like, nom, nom, nom, nom, nom, nom!
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom, nom!
He's a hungry boy.
Alright, LG, guys!
LG!
Alright, we're gonna go all in.
All the cheats, everybody.
Okay, Rage.
Alright, no one shot.
Alright, what do we want for all cheats, guys?
Team Deathmatch capture.
Let's do...
What do we want?
King of the Hill?
I think King of the Hill was really fun.
Um, King of the Hill, kill confirm.
Actually, you guys, what do you guys want?
What do we do?
Team Death?
Team Deathmatch capture the flag.
Flag, kill, confirmed.
Sniper only.
Which one?
We are not doing raid boss, guys.
Kill confirmed.
Capture the flag.
What did I say?
One shot is so fun.
Yeah, but I wanna do all cheats.
King of the Hill?
Okay, King of the Hill.
Alright, King of the Hill.
Let's do it.
Alright.
Let's go.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god, do I...
Oh, we do.
Guys, we have one of the CS players.
I'm so scared.
Oh my god.
Why is everybody so good at aimbot?
Guys, we gotta get to the King of the Hill.
No!
Wait, I know what to do.
It's time.
Maximum spin.
Okay, maybe not.
Guys, it's time.
Maximum spin.
Oh my god.
Guys, we gotta...
Guys, guys, guys, guys.
Guys, what do I...
Guys, if I keep...
Guys, if I never stop shooting, we'll kill them all.
If I...
Guys, if we never stop shooting, we'll kill... Oh, this is a lot harder.
Wait, guys.
Guys, this is a lot harder.
I don't know.
I stood in the open and it worked somehow.
Oh my god, it's working, guys.
Just stand in the open, guys.
It works.
Guys, the no cover thing is actually really hard.
Guys, the no cover...
There's no cover!
What do we do?
It's time, guys.
It gets freaking obliterated instantly.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my... That's it.
That's it.
Guys, that's it.
He has to peek eventually, right?
Guys, we have to be on the point, guys.
We can't win if we're not on the point.
Guys.
Going in.
No!
Okay, hopping is not it.
Hopping is actually not it.
Oh my god, there's so many There's so many.
Why is everybody so good at cheating?
I don't understand!
Guys, just stand in the open.
It works, trust me.
Trust me, it works.
It actually... Oh my god.
Guys, if we all run at the point together, we can't kill us all.
Oh my god.
Guys, guys.
Let's all stay in spawn.
Stay in spawn, guys.
Stay in spawn, then we all run in.
Guys, let's all 3... 2... 1... Go!
Go!
Why are they so good?
I got it.
I know what to do.
I...
Guys, I know what to do.
You too.
That's right.
What you gonna do now, bitch?
You too.
Oh my gosh, my you too.
That's accurate.
What you gonna do now?
I have you too.
Oh no.
Oh no, I have to reload.
Watch this.
You too.
Oh my god.
Why is everyone so good at
fighting?
It should be even.
Everyone, please.
Please, I can't even leave spawn.
Okay, I figured it out.
There we go.
I figured it out.
No!
Guys!
Guys, get on the point.
I'm camping them.
Okay.
Okay, we got this.
There we go.
That should head somewhere, right?
Oh no.
Nice, I got one.
I got one.
Guys, I figured it out.
The power of you too.
Oh my god.
They're throwing...
No, I'm dead.
Guys, guys.
Guys, surround me.
Get in the corner, guys.
Guys, get in the corner.
Get in.
No, get in.
No!
Oh my god.
Oh, thank god.
Spare me of my misery.
It's not my fault.
This map fucking sucks.
I can't deal.
It's not my fault.
Chat, I swear to god.
It's a team game.
It's...
They use util.
They're cheaters.
Why the fuck would they use util?
I can't believe it.
They use utilities.
I picked random.
Random?
Are you allowed?
This is all Clara's fault.
Why would you?
If we all aim bot, there should have been nothing else.
Blaming the team.
Classic CSGO mindset.
But yeah, that was fun.
That was really fun.
Thank you to the devs for sending me free game codes.
Maddie, thank you for the super chat.
GG.
Easy.
Fuck you.
For using util.
That's right.
And cheaters cheat.
If you...
Aim botting is not the cheating.
It's the bhop.
The fucking...
That one guy...
Fucking bhop.
All the way to the flag.
And we had to chase him down.
How the fuck do you chase that down?
Holy shit.
That was fucking crazy.
And then he brought out his...
Fucking minigun.
After he gets the flag.
And I was like, what do we do?
But thank you.
Thank you all for coming today, guys.
Zekka, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'll not be able to play this game.
I'll be laughing myself to death with how chaotic it is.
Especially with the spitting.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And then when the team had two bhoppers.
And you're just like, well, I guess we lose.
I just see one of them get the flag.
And he's gone.
He gets the flag for one second.
And then he's on the other side of the fucking map.
And I'm like, alright.
I guess we lose.
I guess we fucking lose now.
That's really fun though.
I had a great time.
I had a great time playing.
I hope you guys...
I don't know how to bhop!
I don't know how to CSGO bhop.
I know how to Apex bhop.
Apex bhop is so different.
Apex bhopping is for babies.
And I'm like...
I don't know how.
How do they do it?
How the fuck?
I don't know how to Apex bhop.
I don't know how to CS bhop.
Like, how do they do it?
What?
Oh my god.
I've never tactical shooter bhop before.
What?
It's holding the side?
How?
You don't press W?
What?
How do you move forward if you don't press W?
I don't understand.
Film with momentum?
What?
I'll never know.
F2P, how does he do it?
Show us.
Show us your B- What the fuck?
Look at him go!
Look at them go!
He's an actual cheetah!
Oh my god!
Alright, Mama Rin, show your B-hop.
Show us your B-hop.
Oh my god!
Look at them go!
Fucking B-hop!
He's so- oh my god!
He's so fast!
I don't understand!
Oh my god!
I just lose momentum after!
What the fuck do I want to B-hop?
I don't- oh!
Too quick!
The actual game, look at them all B-hopping!
Oh my god, I can't!
I don't get it!
This is the best I can do!
This is- this is the best I can do, guys!
Look at- oh my god, it's so fast!
It's- He's- he's a real cheetah!
They're styling on everyone!
Oh!
That's the best I could do, chat.
That's the- that's the best I could do, guys.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Anyway, guys.
That was really fun, though.
I'm glad I got to try out Cheetah's- Cheetah- Cheater's Cheetah.
Johnny Lacone, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
You know you play Quake 3 Arena with us, you'll learn in no time.
I'm just gonna get absolutely destroyed in Quake.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
You know you can B-hop in Marvel Rivals?
I didn't even realize Marvel Rivals has that mechanic.
Apparently, if you play like DPS characters, you can B-hop.
Um, for some of the DPS characters.
I'm like, what the fuck?
Like, I didn't even realize that.
Um, you B-hop everywhere.
Uh, even on Mantis?
Oh my god.
I'm fucking using my legs regularly like a fucking caveman.
Like- Thank you everybody for watching.
Uh, guys, I think she's ready for CSGO.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Alright guys, it was great playing today.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
I wish I could do like, you know, after a game Zatsudan.
But like, um, I'm trying not to like fuck up my voice too much.
Like, I'm trying to rest as much as I can in between streams.
So I do recover.
By the time- When my voice is fully recovered, we'll have more after game chatting.
We'll have like, after game chatting again.
But for now, uh, I don't wanna overdo it.
So thank you everybody for coming, everyone.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
I'm sorry for my mush mouth there.
I was like- I was like, wait, what did I say?
I was like, oh my god, my flag, my mushy mouth and accent.
It's okay, I meant the cigarette, guys.
I meant the cigarette, guys.
We were in London.
We were shanking, everyone.
We were shanking.
Thank you guys, as always, everybody.
Bye, everyone.
Bye!